yes madam president thank you I am
reading this statement on behalf of the
Commission and I'm here today instead of
vice president reading who is
unavoidably obscene the European
Commission is concerned about recent
media reports that United States
authorities are accessing and processing
on a large scale the data of European
Union citizens using major u.s. online
service providers programs such as the
so called prism and the laws on the
basis of which such programs are
authorized potentially endanger the
fundamental right of to privacy and to
data protection of EU citizens the prism
case as reported in the media is also
likely to reinforce the concerns of EU
citizens regarding the use of their
personal data online and in the cloud
already in 2012
70% of EU citizens were concerned that
their personal data held by companies
could be used for a purpose other than
the one for which it was collected the
prism case as reported in the media also
highlights the difference between the
European Union and the United States
approaches to data protection whereas in
the US legal system only US citizens and
residents benefit from constitutional
safeguards in the European Union
everyone's personal data and the
confidentiality of their communications
are recognized and protected as
fundamental rights irrespective of their
nationality while reports are
particularly worrisome the legal issue
at hand is not a new one it
been tackled by the Commission in the
past to give a single example the
Commission has already raised the matter
of law enforcement access to personal
data of European of European citizens in
the framework of the ongoing
negotiations the United States for a
general data protection agreement in the
field of police and judicial cooperation
as you know very well vice president
reading has received a mandate to
negotiate this agreement with the United
States and she is keeping this house and
in particular members of the Liebherr
committee informed about the progress of
these negotiations the Commission is
asking for clear commitments from the
United States as to the respect of the
fundamental right of EU citizens to data
protection and as to access to judicial
redress in the same way as it is
afforded to United States residents as
far as the prism program is concerned
the Commission will raise this matter
with the United States authorities at
the earliest possible opportunity it
will request clarifications as to
whether access to personal data within
the framework of the prism program is
limited to individual cases and based on
concrete suspicions or if it allows bulk
transfers of data vice president reading
will raise this issue with force and
determination at the upcoming EU us
ministerial on Friday in Dublin beyond
context United States the European Union
can also act by making sure that it
equips itself with robust legislation
able to confront such situations and I
refer in part
to data protection under the current EU
legislation the 1995 Data Protection
Directive when the rights of a you
citizen in a Member State are concerned
it is for the national judge to
determine whether the data can be
lawfully transmitted in accordance with
legal requirements B the National
European or international the Commission
believes that these concerns need to be
further addressed this is the aim of the
proposed general data protection
regulation the reform proposed by Vice
President reading maintains the current
high level of data protection in deal by
updating citizens rights guaranteeing
they know vendor privacy has been
violated and making sure that when their
consent is required the consent is real
more specifically the EU data protection
reform should ensure that the European
Union is able to tackle situations such
as the prism program through its data
protection rules with a clear provision
on territorial scope non-european
companies when offering goods and
services to European consumers will have
to apply the EU data protection law in
full a broad definition of personal data
clear responsibilities for processors
and strong rules for international
transfers recital 90 of the proposed
general protection regulation reflects
our view that in order to avoid
conflicts of jurisdiction excess by
third country law enforcement
authorities to the personal data of EU
citizens
held on the servers of US companies
should be done via established legal
channels such as the EU u.s. mutual
legal assistance agreements the European
Parliament has submitted amendments to
further clarify in the provisions of the
regulation the conditions under which
the judgment of a court or a tribunal of
a third country is enforceable under EU
law the Commission will look at these
proposals honourable members Madam
President the Commission believes that
the quick adoption of this proposal
would resolve any legal loopholes
created when companies collect and
handle personal data of European
citizens and face two different
sovereigns
the Commission therefore counts on this
Parliament to support the objectives and
principles of the EU data protection
reform and work on a swift adoption of
the package give the floor to
Commissioner board for his concluding
remarks thank you very much madam
president
and the Commission I must say shares the
European Parliament's concerns on this
prism scandal and I shall inform vice
president reading of our discussion
today I must also state that mrs.
reading would address the Liebherr
comment committee on the 19th of June
which means that she will not only
discuss and refer with the Liebherr
committee on the developments which will
take place until that day but will also
refer to the Committee on her
negotiations and her meetings in Dublin
next Friday in factual raise our shared
concerns administrative meeting next
Friday in Dublin and will also request
from Clara
occasions from United States Attorney
General Holder this was a good debate
Madam President
even though short and of course there
were two trains of thought which are not
contradictory to each other one of them
is that we should clarify things with
the United States and make it clear that
whenever a European citizen information
is concerned European rules should apply
and that we are not happy with the level
of protection of data information from
the United States in particular even if
you read as Mr Morris Morris said the
Guardian there is reference by the
whistleblower to the facility with which
information could be accessed by the
very person who has leaked this
information in fact he said the
government has granted he's referring to
US government the government has granted
itself power it is not entitled to there
is no public oversight the result is
people like myself have the latitude to
go further than they are allowed to so
we are entitled to ask questions in the
next ministerial summit on whether this
has been done as regards European
citizens at the same time I appreciate
mr. Kirk hopes remarks that let us not
forget who the enemy is and I can
comment as a former Minister of Interior
for 10 years
what would the fight against organized
crime and terrorism be without the
collection of proper intelligence but
the frustration of any law enforcement
agency is it should not be a frustration
but that is it is considered to be so
that's why terrorists and organized
crime have no rules to go by law
enforcement agencies in a democratic
country ruled by rule of law cannot use
anything but the gloves of law in order
to fight terrorism which is why I
appreciate the comments of those
including mr. Webber and others who have
said we have a special relationship with
our us partners we have solved important
investigations regarding prevention of
terrorism through shared information
with our special partnership but no one
should use this special relationship not
to abide by the law and not to abide by
international standards so this is the
fine balancing act of retaining this
partnership but because there is a
partnership it entails not only rights
but deeper obligations because if the
relationship is special
then the obligations should be special
as well and no one should be taken for
granted so I appreciate also madam in
veltz comments on this issues bearing in
mind also what mr. Kirk Hope said about
who the proper enemy is and I would like
also to recall that in the context of
the proposal for a reform of data
protection in Europe and they appreciate
the positive comments which have been
made by different members as to the
importance of adopting this new package
proposed by madam rating the Commission
has made it clear that the
extraterritorial application of laws by
third countries may be in breach of
international law and establish and
establishes the reform establishes legal
channels that should be used the
Commission is ready to consider any
improvements the European Parliament
would consider necessary in this respect
that is why we need to work together for
a swift adoption of the package that
some in the Member States would like to
see delayed it is our common interest to
work hand in hand in the direction the
more so in view of these recent
developments
thank you very much you very much
commissioner borj chakir Sanaa defeat
Obama knows me Austin Muricy idiotic see
in Access Tichenor delcostello Tammy
Abreu Becky's voices prosto a Poros Sado
sotol agostina ECE tria que se para Don
Satan error so Sanader who Martinez